my name is Sully I'm a software engineer
here at Google and I'm joined by another
engineer if it costs i'm bielagus so
Vikas has been working on K native what
is K native what is the problem that
it's aiming to solve and you know what
our customers going to get out of this
sure that's a great question so with the
K native we are really targeting at
solving the developer facing problems
that you have at kubernetes which is
there's a very heavy cognitive load for
understanding the system and being able
to operate it so it's very good at
targeting operators with the K native
you are trying to go ahead and make
running your applications on kubernetes
super easy and simple so that when you
come into it you're like hey I just want
to write code here's my code don't screw
it up that's what we tried to help you
solve so how does that actually work is
this like it's a platform that'll be
deployed on top of kubernetes and then
you deploy against it yeah so it
basically is adding fusee RDS they are
very principled so we have a build so
that because in the server list land you
typically think about the source code
again we don't want you to think about
how does that get into running code so
we have something that is source so
source handles how do you go into gets
from github and turn in the running code
so we have a build there's some CR these
that handle that for you we also have
serving which actually decides how do
you want to go and run your software as
in you know these are like if you want
to do route manipulation to canaries
experiments and everything else like
that you bb make that very easy for you
and also we have another set of CRTs for
eventing so typically in the serverless
land many people think of serverless
only as functions but it's not as I
mentioned but we also handle the
eventing so that if you want to go ahead
and for example say hey I just got some
data in cloud storage
I would like to transform it which is
kind of like the canonical example we
make that easy for you as well we can
say hey when this happens over here run
this code for me over there and it does
a code need to be in any specific
language or nope absolutely not so
there's a couple of things we think of
everything as containers so whatever you
put in that container is up to you also
we don't really make a really big of a
distinction but
whether it's fun a function or whether
it's an application because in both ends
you have some code that you know run so
we don't want we don't make you as a
developer have to choose your tool chain
upfront you can just say hey here's my
code and then be decoupled the what do
you want to do with it run to respond to
events or run it as in response to the
user it's tough oh that sounds awesome
so what's the current status of this
project we just released 0.2 version and
we are working hard and getting 0.3 in
early January and we are trying to get
to 1.0 in the late summer early fall but
the heavy focus and operational aspect
so that we can actually do things like
upgrade and so forth for you and this
will be available to gke customers as an
add-on or yeah yeah so actually today at
the keynote they they demoed a little
bit of that so when you come into gke
you have a little check box where you
can say sprinkle some serverless
goodness on me kay native me know it's
that's super cool so is this a project
that's being led only by Google or is
there you know involvement outside is it
an open source project yep it's an open
source project it's on github.com /k
native and we definitely wanted to go
and build a big tent bring a lot of
friends because there's a lot of
experience in this space and vdm gonna
come in and say like oh we know at all
we'd really wanted to go and bring our
friends understand how do we build the
best system possible because a lot of
these problems we're being solved by
many companies at the same time so let's
solve those boring problems once and
then focus on building really cool
things for the developers that's awesome
and is this what serverless is I've
heard that word so many times but I
don't really understand it can you
explain it to me
so for server list yeah it means
different things to different people to
me
it basically means couple of different
things it means that you as a developer
don't have to worry about things like
infrastructure okay so the
infrastructure kind of gets hidden away
for you the second point is you should
only pay for what you use so if you have
some application that is not taking air
traffic or you have a function that is
not being executed you shouldn't have to
pay for that and lastly it should also
mean you should be able to go ahead and
be idiotic me
you shouldn't have to learn a new way of
doing things if you want to write some
code write some code and let me just say
run it for me and lastly we want to make
sure this is something that we've heard
a lot from our customers in the past
which is it should be free of lock-in so
I want to be able to run anywhere I want
to do so there obviously are solutions
in this space but some of those don't
meet the criteria for the last one we
just I want to run it wherever I want to
run it cool so for folks who want to get
involved either in development or to
kick the tires what where would they go
what would they do
sure github.com /k native all one word
and there's there's a lot of great ways
to get involved there there's a vo
obviously welcome people to come in and
contribute whether it's in the form of
filing issues or feature requests or or
looking at the documentation and
experimenting with things or actually
putting together some PRS come on come
help us awesome
well hopefully people will take a look
at that and start getting involved let's
switch gears a little bit and talk about
cube con so this is not your first q con
can you tell us a little bit about your
background yeah sure so yeah I've been
involved with kubernetes from pretty
much the very first days so after Joe
and Brendon and Greg I was the next
person contributing code to it so been
around for a while in that space yeah so
being around the kubernetes block yeah I
mean so you were one of the original
cofounders of kubernetes and you're you
know the fifth Beatle so to speak how
have you seen things of all since then
oh my goodness is just amazing seeing so
many people here it just blows my mind
it just it's amazing every time like
every cube can I go try cool so a last
question and I'll put you a little bit
on the spot what is the coolest memory
or your favorite memory of cue con ever
it I have to say it's the first one it
was just the fact that he's just like
here's a party does anybody show up but
it was like yeah actually people showed
up and then here we are but yeah at the
first one it was people definitely
showed up all right it was a pleasure
talking to you thank you so much thank
you very much thank you
[Music]